first can you just say and spell your
first and last name for me
my name is dr amy stone a-m-y-s-t-o-n-e
great and then your title position and
where you work
i'm an assistant professor of
microbiology and immunology at toro
university nevada
great so we're here to talk a little bit
about this cova 19 study that you guys
are doing and also looking for
volunteers so
first just kind of break down what
exactly the goal of this study is and
what you hope to accomplish
the goal of our study is to understand
how the las vegas metro area and clark
county as a whole
have been affected by
the virus
that causes covet 19 immunologically so
we're looking at antibodies and so we
want to understand how
how are the antibodies being produced by
our community and so what that tells us
is it tells us a little bit about
protection it tells us about who has
been infected and it tells us about who
is getting vaccinated all of this
information can help us understand where
we need to put our resources as the
public health efforts and lead to
hopefully
new treatments and vaccines that will
help prevent and treat this disease
and if you can kind of break it down
maybe in layman's terms in terms of once
you collect this blood sample how
exactly you go about figuring out that
information that you're looking for yeah
after we collect the blood we bring it
into the lab and we separate it into a
couple different sections so first we
take out the liquid and within the
liquid are the proteins which is also
where the antibodies are so that's where
we're going to find
those
molecules that are going to help protect
us against the virus
we also are looking at white blood cells
we want to know how the white blood
cells are able to function in people who
have been vaccinated versus have not
been vaccinated people who have had the
disease versus people who haven't had
the disease and what we're hoping to
find by looking at these white blood
cells is if there's any indication to
how we might predict if someone is going
to have severe disease or mild disease
and so
it sounds like you're looking to get
these samples from both folks who are
unvaccinated and vaccinated correct
yes we are looking to get samples from
people who are vaccinated and
unvaccinated people who have been
infected and people who haven't been
infected we really need to look at
everyone to get a clear picture of
what's happening in our community and so
we can't
exclude any one of those groups because
they are representative of our community
and uh if you can kind of
explain the
how it works when you look at these
antibodies and you uh
try to decide the efficacy of the
vaccines what exactly are you looking
for to make that determination
so when we take the antibodies what
we're going to be doing is
seeing how well they attach to the virus
so we have pieces of the virus that are
being targeted by these antibodies so
the virus is kind of like a ball we've
all seen that image and the parts that
are sticking out of the ball that's
called the spike protein
we want our antibodies to bind to that
spike protein because that's what what's
going to stop those viruses from
attacking us and infecting us
and so we want to know how
well do those antibodies from our
community attach to that spike protein
and does that actually stop the virus
from getting into
someone's cells
what do you mention
i'm not trying to answer that fully
tonight no you're fine
um and
earlier you talked about you know
gathering the information from this
study and then determining where best to
put resources so what exactly are those
resources that you're talking about
we've partnered with the southern nevada
public health district to share our data
we're looking at zip codes and where
people who report either being
vaccinated or being infected from this
information by zip code we can look at
where some where there might be hot
spots of infection and then the public
health district can send out the
interventions that we need and make sure
that people are
being protected and making sure that
those areas have the
clinical workers the healthcare workers
they need in order to support their
community and maintain the health of
their community
i know currently you know within the
clark county area we have you know those
current zip code maps right that show
like you said hot spots for covet
infection and then areas that are maybe
are more vaccinated than others uh is
this
you know looking at the antibodies
specifically is this maybe more of a
accurate indication is that kind of your
your hope when you when you do get this
data to kind of supplement those
existing tools that we have
our data will supplement the existing
tools that we have that currently show
hot spots because our data will be able
to show the asymptomatic infections when
you are surveilling a community
typically you're only looking at people
who come to the clinic with symptoms our
group is looking at everyone whether
they've had symptoms or not and so we'll
be able to identify people who had no
symptoms that have been affected with
the virus and that will give us a much
better picture of the real level of
transmission as opposed to just the
level of transmission that leads to
clinical disease
that makes sense uh and i know you're
obviously looking for volunteers
um i guess around how many volunteers is
is ideal and do you think
you know if you reach that number will
that be inaccurate representation of
of that population that you're looking
at
we think that around a thousand
participants will be an accurate
representation of the las vegas metro
area um we would always love to have
more more data is always better
and so what we're looking for are just
any individual who is an adult
over 110 pounds so that they can safely
donate blood
um to come out and give us a small
sample of blood
and if we can get a thousand people we
think that will be a really good
representation of our community
i see that you know the goal is to you
know publish findings uh next year um i
know you talk about obviously the the
goal of this is to
figure out where to where to put the
resources how important
is a study like this can you kind of
speak to just the importance of doing
something like this
our type of study is incredibly
important for our community there are
similar studies going on all over the
world however what's happening in other
cities such as seattle new york or l.a
doesn't really represent what's
happening here in las vegas and so we
need this study from our local community
to understand our local needs
great and um obviously you're looking
for people over 18 you mentioned
weighing at least 110 pounds um how how
do people get in touch with you guys to
be a part of this study we're asking
people who are interested in our study
to send us an email
at
t u n
covid 19 study and that's all one word
at gmail.com that's our study gmail
after people contact us we reply with
more information and if they're still
interested we schedule them for the
blood draw we're doing
appointments only and those are going to
be at the southern nevada public health
district maine clinic
that's sort of in the middle of the city
on decatur
is there anything else that you wanted
to add
i'm
yeah
our study is particularly important in
this moment because of the rise in cases
that we've seen here in august and the
rise of the delta variant what we don't
know from a lot of the vaccines is how
long will protection last and how good
is that protection against the delta
variant
our information from this study will be
able to give some of that information
we'll be able to test
individuals antibodies against
the delta variant and see are they
protected or are they not and whether
natural vaccine
natural infection vaccination or
vaccination vaccination after natural
infection will result in good protection
what we really want is to understand how
do we protect our community and there
are so many open questions that really
need answered
great well thank you very much for your
time i really appreciated chatting with
you
thank you so much for giving us the
opportunity to talk about it and share
the information